Okay.
Let's go next to our caller from the seven
nine four, seven nine area code.
Who's calling today from four seven nine.
Oh, David, my name is Jacob.
I'm from Fort Smith, Arkansas.
How you doing today?
Hey, how are you doing Jacob?
I'm doing all right.
So I called you a couple of years ago and
I'm wondering if you're a, I asked you this
specific question and I'm just wondering if
you, you probably may not remember the question,
but like I'm wondering if you will probably
evolved on this question that I'm going to
ask you.
Basically I actually about Medicare for all
right.
And if you think it'll ever be implemented,
but you know, with Bernie Sanders running
to his campaign the way he does and let's
say he does win and uh, the way he plans on
trying to get implemented, you think it's
more likely now, do you think you have evolved
on if he wins that, you know, in the next
five, 10 years we could actually have like
a medical medicare for all system or do you
think it still, cause you said before, back
when I talked to you, it was like a state
by state issue that you probably think is
more likely.
But like with the way Bernie Sanders is, Troy,
that rally, uh, is uh, people that his constituents
or the democratic base.
I mean I'm just thinking it's more likely
he could possibly get it implemented, but
I don't know.
Yeah, I think that now my perspective is that
it's more likely that there will be a national
medicare for all implementation than I thought
whenever you call it a couple of years ago.
I still think that there are just significant
barriers and I think that the idea of doing
it at the state level still at least initially
doing state single payer is still not a bad
idea, particularly because the state's most
likely to first implement it are the states
where the math will be most favorable to actually
doing it.
But I've actually, the way I've evolved is
a different one on medicare for all.
I am more open than ever to other ways of
achieving universal coverage in a nonprofit
non predatory way.
And this has become a reality from you just
by learning more about other systems, whether
it's the German system, French or UK, Canada,
et Cetera.
So I'm a huge supporter of expanding Medicare
to medicare for all, it would be multiple
times better than what we have.
But I also, and I said this on the Joe Rogan
program and it was misquoted.
Interestingly, um, medicare as a base has
some issues.
Of course they are solvable issues.
So my position is I'm open to any path that
takes the vulture capitalism out of healthcare
and it makes sure that everybody has access
to care regardless of ability to pay.
I will have a conversation about any of those
systems.
And I think Medicare for all is a good option,
but it's just one option.
Yes.
And I agree with you there because like with
people that are not able to afford it, I mean
it just makes sense that you know, when you
need help you should be able to get it without
having to um, you know, break the bank, you
know, I mean any type of, I think Medicare
for all would be good and you know, cause
they're always going to be rich people and
poor people no matter what kind of, especially
living in a capitalist society, there's always
going to be somebody at the bottom of the
ladder that they're going to need help if
they said people get sick.
So I do agree with you.
So.
All right, very good.
Appreciate the call.
You're out.
Audio sounding a bit odd.
So I'm going to let you go.
But yes, my view, if it has evolved, it has
evolved to only in being more optimistic.
For sure.